hi there i'm ryan right today I'm going
to be presenting the news I found most
interesting in the last week of August
2015 the first official photo for a sexy
actor Michael Fassbender has been
released for the new assassins creed
movie fans of the video game may be
disappointed to find out the character
he's playing is not in the video games
but when has stayed true to a video game
actually worked I mean how do we know
we've never done it Vin Diesel reveals
that before december 2015 he will begin
shooting XXX sequel three or two I don't
know there's a one with ice cube count
Mario creator and Nintendo ambassador
insert Japanese name that I don't know
how to pronounce reveals that Nintendo
is now open to film adaptations I think
they should adapt this Super Nintendo
game Terminator to Judgment Day because
it's been like 15 years and I still
don't know how to beat the first level
it's been announced that the new film
franchise a blade will be based upon the
upcoming female character who is blades
daughter meaning she is black and I like
me some dark chocolate you know when I'm
lying I'm gonna have sex with a black
girl kidding i'm fine with my girlfriend
imagine she's a black room no specific
face just Veronica but darker if you
were excited for the Mad Max fury road
director George Miller to helm the new
man of steel sequel get ready to be
disappointed because the man of steel
sequel is on permanent hold open up your
heart let the feelings of shame and
disappointment come in now kill yourself
Luke Bracey the actor who's filling in
for the keanu reeves role in Point Break
has landed a lead role in mel gibson's
world war two pitcher in order to get
the actor mel gibson had to sell his
Laker seats get it because of those
domestic violent calls he made to his
ex-girlfriend those domestic violent
calls were so funny Joaquin Phoenix will
reunite with M night Shyamalan for a new
film produced by bloom house M night
Shyamalan has tried to ruin Paul
Giamatti's career dev patel's career and
Will Smith's career let's see if he
could finally take down Joaquin Phoenix
Borderlands the science-fiction
steampunk Western video game is being
produced by Lions Gate into a film the
video game has been considered one of
the best to possibly adapt into a movie
but i prefer the hollywood way where you
don't stick true to the game at all
already made a trip like that then or
not alright guys well that's it for my
movie news of the week if you do to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on facebook
instagram twitter vine periscope and
last but not least you could catch my
videos on latino review com people think
I'm a racist so I joined the site to
prove I am NOT a racist